The SCP Foundation is responsible for containing
some of the most dangerous forces in the world.
Without them, we’d all be at the mercy of
the Plague Doctor, walking through the world
and killing with a touch.
Anyone could be snapped up by SCP-106 and
dragged to a painful death in his pocket dimension
lair.
There would be no one to stop SCP-682 from
devouring all living things in sight, and
no one to hold back the dreaded Scarlet King
from breaching our world and destroying life
as we know it.
We owe them a lot, for sure, and they’ve
earned at least a thank you card and an Edible
Arrangement, but containing the anomalies
of the world comes at a pretty steep cost.
They’re essentially fighting a war against
a whole host of world-ending entities, and
when you’re at war, there are bound to be
casualties.
For some people and creatures out there, the
most terrifying monster isn’t 096 trying
to swallow them whole for looking at its face,
or 173 just waiting for them to turn their
back so it can snap their neck.
For the unfortunates that find themselves
in the wrong place at the wrong time, the
scariest monster in the world is the SCP
Foundation
itself.
A decade ago, the SCP Foundation was attempting
to recapture SCP-682, which
had breached containment
and was tearing its way through the southern
Congo region.
Unable to contain the monster by other means,
and desperate to stop it from killing any
more civilians, the Foundation decided to
implement some rather extreme measures.
They deployed a variety of chemical agents
and poisonous gasses in an attempt to slow
the creature down, but they had no effect.
As the enormous reptile stomped its way toward
a nearby river, with a highly populated village
waiting on the other side, the Foundation
made the decision to take things up a notch.
They launched an aerial strike, deploying
several aircrafts to drop explosives on the
area around the river.
They destroyed large portions of the riverbank,
but the environmental impact was considered
to be a necessary evil.
When the smoke finally cleared, and the deafening
roars of the beast had gone quiet, they stopped
their bombing campaign and dispatched Foundation
operatives to the scene.
There, they found the bones of SCP-682, which
were quickly brought into custody before the
creature could begin to heal itself.
The mission was considered a success, and
they were ready to pull out all of their staff
and head back to the nearest Foundation Site,
when one officer spotted something floating
in the nearby river.
It looked like a group of human corpses face
down in the water, their bodies badly burned.
Concerned that civilians from a nearby village
had been inadvertently present for the bombing
campaign, a team of officers
was sent to investigate
the river more closely.
What they found was not a group of dead humans,
but something else entirely.
There were, all along the river bank and floating
in the water, approximately 212 specimens
of a previously unknown humanoid species.
The bodies were clustered in groups of three
to five, appearing to belong to the same family
unit or social group.
Many of them were frozen in positions of fear
or an attempt to defend themselves, with some
observing personnel comparing them to the
victims of the Pompeii eruption, stuck in
their final terrified moments.
What appeared to be parents and children held
onto each other, some covered their faces,
others lay in a fetal position.
It seemed that they had known something was
coming to kill them, but they did not have
the time or the understanding necessary to
escape it.
Several of the bodies were removed from the
river for autopsy and examination, in order
to understand more about this new, possibly
already extinct, species.
They were humanoid organisms
with an indeterminable
genus and species.
They resembled tall, thin humans with absolutely
no body hair and elongated limbs.
The most unusual aspect of the creatures was
in their mouths: their teeth were serrated
and sharp, resembling those of a crocodile.
In spite of these monstrous teeth, an autopsy
revealed that there was no human flesh present
in any of the creatures’ stomachs, instead
suggesting a diet of fish, livestock, and
whatever else they could peacefully scavenge.
Every last corpse was removed from the area
and incinerated, to prevent any civilians
from coming across them and asking questions.
Just when the Foundation personnel were finally
packing up and getting ready to leave the
river once and for all, they heard something.
It was a mournful sound, something between
a man bellowing, and a wild animal yelping
in pain.
Something nearby was still very much alive,
and it was screaming.
The officers followed the sound, and spotted
one surviving specimen of the crocodile people,
lying along the bank of the river.
It was holding its face in its hands, curled
up into a ball near the water, and it was
wailing in agony.
There were no visible injuries on the creature’s
body, but it was clearly extremely distressed.
One officer attempted to approach the creature,
calling out to it that he meant no harm, and
wanted to get it some medical attention.
It looked up at the officer with wide eyes,
and its cries went quiet.
The officer grabbed his weapon, afraid that
the creature might suddenly rush him, but
instead, it ran into the river.
It jumped into the water, plunging beneath
the surface, and began thrashing around.
After a moment of watching it struggle, the
officer realized what was happening: the creature
was trying to drown itself.
He abandoned protocol completely at that moment,
diving into the water and pulling the struggling
creature back to shore.
It coughed up water for several minutes, all
the while trying to crawl back into the water.
When the creature had finally calmed down,
it was brought into Foundation custody with
no further resistance.
It appeared to be the last living member of
whatever strange human-crocodile hybrid species
was living in that river, and it was designated
SCP-6415.
Since it was brought into Foundation custody,
SCP-6415’s behavior has been largely very
consistent.
Some SCPs are constantly attempting to escape
from their containment or killing an endless
revolving door of D-Class personnel, but 6415
is not one of those anomalies.
It is not aggressive, in spite of its crocodilian
characteristics, and it’s content to eat
the food provided by the Foundation.
It is fed a diet of raw meat, mostly beef
and goat, which is provided fresh daily.
The Foundation was curious to see if the creature
could be pushed to be
aggressive if its circumstances
were made a little less comfortable.
They deprived it of food for several days,
but it did not seem to notice or even care
much aside from occasionally looking at the
door to see if new food had come.
They tried sleep deprivation next, blaring
a loud siren sound over
speakers in the containment
chamber any time the creature was observed
lying down or closing its eyes.
It became listless and visibly exhausted but
did not act out violently at this either.
After this testing, its ordinary feeding and
sleep schedule was resumed.
For the most part, all that SCP-6415 does
is eat and sleep.
There is, however, one notable exception.
At random intervals, SCP-6415 will begin to
cry, sobbing intensely and appearing to be
in a state of overwhelming distress.
Its cries are so loud that they can be heard
from several halls away, and have caused hearing
damage to personnel in the room with it.
There is no way to stop the creature from
crying once it has started, though providing
it with a hot cup of tea, a soft blanket,
or a hug from a particularly brave and eager
D-class has caused it to cry a bit more quietly.
Once it is finished crying, after several
hours of non-stop weeping, it will lie down
on the ground and not cry anymore for weeks
at a time.
For a time, SCP-6415 was considered to be
lacking human intelligence, and its containment
procedures were changed to reflect that.
It was held in a standard humanoid containment
chamber in the light containment wing of Site
619, with soundproof walls.
Because it displayed no threatening behavior,
it was considered unnecessary to have any
guards placed outside 6415’s chamber.
However, after Incident 6415-01, the Foundation’s
understanding of the creature
changed dramatically.
The Incident occurred when several D-Class
personnel were sent into 6415’s containment
chamber to feed it, and they found a harrowing
sight.
On the wall of the chamber, the entity had
scratched a message with its fingernails.
Its fingertips were bloodied and torn; its
hands noticeably wounded from what must have
been a great deal of effort.
It did not acknowledge the personnel that
entered the room, instead, it just sat on
the floor, staring at its work on the wall,
cradling its injured hands and crying.
Its shoulders shook with the force of its
sobs, and its tears fell to the ground, pooling
around it.
The D-Class personnel were later unable to
report what they had seen without beginning
to cry themselves, but eventually calmed down
enough to report what the creature had written:
“Please bring them back.”
It was a desperate plea for the Foundation
to somehow reunite it with its lost family.
They had previously thought the creature to
be a simple animal, incapable of understanding
its own reality or communicating through clear
language.
This proved that the creature understood very
well what had happened to it, and was feeling
the loss of its loved ones fully.
One D-Class officer noticed a scrap of paper,
likely a piece of butcher paper from one of
the creature’s previous meals, with a picture
drawn on it.
It was a crude sketch, but its subject was
easily recognizable: it was the Southern Congo
river where 6415 was first discovered, with
three creatures splashing in the water.
The largest one resembled SCP-6415, and it
was swimming alongside a slightly smaller
adult of its species and a much smaller creature
that appeared to be a juvenile of the same
species.
Context clues indicated that this was a drawing
of SCP-6415’s family, its partner, and their
child.
At first, the Foundation researchers were
uncertain who exactly the creature was referring
to in its initial message, but this drawing
made it perfectly clear.
It wanted its family back.
It is uncertain whether or not the creature
is aware that its family is dead, but it clearly
feels their absence just the same and believes
the Foundation might have the power to end
its suffering.
Foundation personnel who were exposed to the
details of the Incident became inconsolable,
falling into a deep bout of depression brought
on by a sense of shame and responsibility.
When counseling sessions proved ineffective,
the emotionally affected staff were given
amnestics to wipe their memory of the Incident,
and of 6415 altogether.
One employee, Research Assistant Cheryl Cruz,
attempted to release the creature from its
containment, insisting that it deserved to
roam free.
However, when she opened
the door to its containment
facility, the creature made no move to leave.
It just stared at her, tears in its eyes,
as if it knew that it had nowhere else to
go.
Research Assistant Cruz was given a powerful
amnestic, and relieved of her position at
the Foundation.
Her current whereabouts are unknown.
In order to prevent any more reckless behavior
from sympathetic staff, the message scratched
into the wall was painted over, and the sketch
recovered from its chamber was destroyed.
But even if the memories and evidence of the
creature’s pain are gone, anyone walking
by its chamber can still hear it weeping.
It is uncertain what the containment procedures
for SCP-6415 will become.
It is not simply an animal and clearly understands
language, though it appears to be incapable
of speech.
If it could talk, whatever it said would surely
be heartbreaking.
For now, the entity remains in its cell, serving
as a grim reminder of the guilt that weighs
on the Foundation’s conscience.
No matter what they do with 6415, they cannot
take back what they did.
They cannot lift the weight of the creature’s
grief, or bring back its lost family.
It is the lone survivor, sitting in its Foundation
cell, weeping for its broken heart and begging
the Foundation for the one thing it can never
do: Bring them back.
Now go check out “SCP-1762 - Where The Dragons
Went” and “SCP-348 - A Gift from Dad”
for more heart-wrenching SCP’s!